no one seems to know
how many americans there are in
afghanistan initially we were told
you know a few thousand then it became
more like five or seven thousand and we
were told it's as many as ten or even
fifteen thousand but we're not being
given the number and now gen saki
spokes woman at the white house
is saying that there are no americans
stranded in afghanistan does the
president have a sense that most of the
criticism is not of leaving afghanistan
it's the way that he has ordered it to
happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no american
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i said when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home we are
going to bring them home now this is a
very clever trick
it's it's not all that clever because
it's so transparent but it's it's at
least clever in theory
jen saki is being asked a question by
peter ducey one of the last reporters
left in america
and the question is
what about these americans who are
stranded in afghanistan
and jan saki says
we are not
going to strand any americans in
afghanistan
you see that he's saying in the present
tense what about the americans currently
right now undeniably stranded in
afghanistan
and she says no no there will not be
anyone ultimately who is stranded in
afghanistan the question isn't about
your promises jensaki the question isn't
about your predictions frankly the white
house's predictions on afghanistan have
been pretty bad they've been completely
wrong actually and even the president
has admitted that
and the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff has admitted that and
basically everybody involved in this
evacuation has admitted that all their
predictions turned out to be false they
didn't even think it was possible that
it would go this bad so please
for a moment spare me your assurances
and your predictions about what will
happen in the future what about the
americans stranded right now
no we will not strand
any americans in afghanistan oh really
like you won't lose all of our
protective equipment and have it taken
over by the taliban like you won't lose
the kabul embassy like you won't like
you won't like you won't give me a break
like you won't prevent americans from
being caught there in the first place
give me a break
by the way two hours prior to jen saki's
preposterous statement politico reports
that the pentagon confirmed
another mission to rush rescue americans
stranded in kabul
that's the language from politico
actually the verb
or in this case the adjective stranded
pentagon confirms latest mission to
rescue americans stranded
in kabul
listen to how they do it this is this is
uh in in politico apart from that
mission
a pentagon spokesperson john kirby said
at a news briefing monday that there had
been quote at least one additional
instance where rotary airlift was used
to help americans get from outside the
airport into the airport he declined to
elaborate further saying i think i'm
just going to have to leave it at that
today
they used
rotary air lift
what is
rotor well there's only two this there's
three ways to get something into the air
there's an airplane there's a rocket
ship and there's a helicopter and this
one's rotary
so it's not a jet it's not like fixed
wind oh it's a oh it's a helicopter oh
you're talking about a helicopter but
you don't want to use the word
helicopter because helicopter evokes
those images out of vietnam out of the
fall of saigon
the worst american foreign policy
debacle
until now
oh that's so they're going to use all of
these youth as always the left is going
to use all of these euphemisms they're
going to try to redefine all the words
they're going to try to use
mealy-mouthed jargon they're going to
try to play around with verbs and
adjectives to try to pretend that
americans are not currently stranded
like they're not being evacuated as fast
as they can though most experts think
there's not nearly enough time before
the august 31st deadline
to get the americans out of afghanistan
stop
don't go don't leave me i need you i
need you to go to apple podcasts or
spotify or google play or stitcher or
whatever whatever you wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael
knowles show
click
subscribe
then wait for that to populate in your
feed maybe leave it a five star review
if you don't mind and leave a comment
right here and say hello to me on
youtube we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]